let's talk about
what could be the most explosive
issue of this campaign
if the mass media would get a hold of
and do something about it but they're
covering it up
and that is they you know you were
talking about that in the government
involvement and drugs
there've been government investigations
are good private investigations that
we've interviewed a lot of people
protect c_i_a_ flip
who have talked about the c_i_a_
involvement in drug operations for many
decades
hits
public knowledge so once again the media
and i was thinking about it
oliver north
and his
people involved with me
the contras
uh... been running drug operations
cocaine primarily bring it back into the
united states
and there are other uh... investigations
which show that joy to bushes office
donald gregg particularly the people he
was working with
they've been uh... supervising an
enormous drug operation
which once again was bringing sending
uh...
illegal arms are down to uh... the
contras in elsewhere
and bringing cocaine and other types
drugs back into the united states
neither the democrats are talking about
this now
are the libertarians talking about this
into the put this into the framework of
the drug loss situation that you're
talking about out we talk about a whole
lot of course we always have the trouble
getting the attention that we think it
deserves there have been a few democrats
had talked about certain carey's office
as there is some work
he's done a lot of the investigation
right and uh... i think he's onto
something and i think we've gotten some
other information to course
that uh... george of the c_i_a_ has
given noriega over the years two hundred
thousand dollars a year your yes and
that they kept feeding him money even
wind that bush was the head of the
c_i_a_ mining jeep at george bush is sat
deep into uh... well over there is het
sally s we once of uh... if i thought
george bush knew about as much was going
on is as ronald reagan by george bush
did a lot more about what was having the
c_i_a_ gaadi
uh... reagan was tried more removed from
what i mean just by his own personality
of his agers only uh... about idyllic
bush through his office in through the
roof of the hands of the factories was a
member of the city a head of the c_i_a_
but he was very very close to it he
knows exactly what was happening yeah i
believe the rule that once the c_i_a_
member always a c_i_a_ member and i
think it's awful interesting can you
imagine you with a lot of a few of us in
this country of all the sudden we knew
that the leader in the soviet union
would be the head k_g_b_ agents didn't
compare we take our heads c_i_a_ agent
put him
you know potentially have opted pac
conference
unfortunately i wish that we can get
this information to help out
and i continue to talk about about
buying sadly believe that there will be
very little sahab which means that the
democrat
aren't doing it that means they're
involved here involve all staff i don't
think there's any doubt about it i mean
it was a even some other got reported in
the iran-contra scandal is we didn't
know that there were dot drugs be drugs
involved in
and they were selling drugs that book i
think that might be the number one
reason path for the drug laws i mean
they use in play on the good people of
america supporter but i think number one
reason
he has not not to have high prices for
some uh... two-bit drug dealer as much
as to raise the funds necessary to for
governments to do illegal things whether
it's some terrace government someplace
or well as our own c_i_a_ tear fund
programs that they can't get congress to
find uh... i think it's tragic and uh...
sooner we get rid of the drug laws uh...
the sooner this with him